[Music]
teachers unions the Democrats biggest
Super PAC spending big on Democrats with
just nine days until the midterm the
groups like the AFT and Nea pouring
millions of dollars into Political
campaigns between 2021 and 2022 with
nearly all of it of course going to
left-wing candidates
here to react is turning point USA
founder Charlie Kirk Charlie thanks for
being here you travel the country you
talk to parents students are is what the
Nea and aft what the teachers unions
what they're selling in these ads is
anyone buying it after what they pulled
during covet
no but the enormity and the volume of
resources is quite remarkable I have to
tell you though the Nea and the AFT
they're so worried that there is a
parent's party that is growing Across
America that is bipartisan that it's
diverse that is across socio-economic
lines it is parents that are starting to
show up at school board meetings and I
think what we're going to see with the
midterm elections coming up just around
the corner is we're going to see this
hidden parent vote it's very hard to see
in the polling but you look at the last
couple years you look at the lockdowns
you look at the mass mandates the
vaccine mandates the decline in math and
reading scores this is really hard to
pinpoint because it's that kind of
hidden Suburban voter they might not
have liked Trump but they don't like it
all what's happened in their local
schools and it's the Democrats that
owned all of it I think you're going to
see it materialize in the Minnesota
Michigan and Wisconsin governors race in
particular those are state-based type
races that were overly Draconian with
their lockdowns and the Nea and the AFT
are so worried that school choice pieces
of legislation like we just passed here
in Arizona are sweeping the country with
Newfound momentum I like the sound of
that the parents party and a hidden vote
and if if races in Minnesota Wisconsin
and Michigan are tight man what an
election night it's going to be uh and I
know things are looking up in in your
state of Arizona as well with two great
candidates at the top uh one of which
Carrie Lake will have on the program in
just about 30 minutes but first Charlie
we want to get to another topic you've
highlighted very well you've got a new
documentary out called border battle
take a watch
this isn't a war that anybody even wants
to talk about
we are at War
describe the cartel Pure Evil
the Turning Point USA docu-series
Charlie tell us about it
yeah from the education cartel that
we're just talking about now to the drug
cartel we've been spending about nine
months on this we're a border state here
in Arizona we make the argument that
actually every single state is a border
state it's a project to educate millions
of Americans about what's actually
happening on the southern border people
could check it out at salemnow.com and
what we did is we embedded with border
patrol with ice with the great Sheriff
Mark Lamb to educate people on the drugs
the fentanyl the crime the child sex
trafficking and what's happening because
of a porous Southern border I think this
is a major issue that people don't quite
understand they they oh yeah people are
crossing no no this issue of sovereignty
issue of our kids and right now Across
America there are kids that are taking
fentanyl pills that were just that just
waltzed across the southern border
because our federal government allowed
it to happen so it's salemnow.com if
people want to check it out it's making
a very very big impact Pete I think
every American needs to properly educate
themselves on the border so we could
solve this problem once and for all
so on our first topic it's the parents
party versus the perverts party uh and
then you've got sovereignty versus
Anarchy that's basically if you want to
break it down it's a sanity election uh
Choose Wisely Choose Wisely yes as if
your life and your kids depend on it
Charlie Kirk you're the man thank you
thank you